THAT.
THAT WAS A WONDERFUL SUMMATION
OF AN AMAZING LIFE AND I
APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: GEORGE HW BUSH'S
CHIEF OF STAFF IN AMERICAN LIFE
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT WITH HIS
MEMORIES.
GOVERNOR, THANKS A LOT FOR
COMING ON.
WHAT ARE YOUR MEMORIES OF
BARBARA BUSH?
>> SHE WAS A GREAT LADY AND A
GREAT FRIEND.
AND IT'S A GREAT LOSS.
IT'S AMAZING HOW SHE WAS THE
ROCK OF THAT FAMILY AND THEY ALL
ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
WHEN I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE, I
WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH HER.
WE DEVELOPED A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP AND THE '88
CAMPAIGN AND SHE COULD SEE
THROUGH PEOPLE.
SHE COULD SENSE THE REAL PEOPLE
FROM A PHONIES AND I THINK SHE
SENSED THAT I REALLY HAD THE
PRESIDENT'S BACK SO WE GOT ALONG
REALLY, REALLY WELL.
IT MADE MY LIFE EASY.
>> Tucker: IT WAS IMPORTANT TO
GET ALONG WITH HER THEN.
>> IT CERTAINLY WAS.
HER FAMILY KNEW THAT MORE THAN
ANYONE ELSE.
>> Tucker: HER SON, THE
PRESIDENT, 43RD PRESIDENT USED
TO TALK ABOUT HER A LOT WITH A
MIXTURE OF WHAT SOUNDED LIKE
LOVE, HONOR, AND MAY BE A LITTLE
OF FEAR.
>> HE CALLED HER THE ENFORCER.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
>> SHE REALLY WAS AN EXCEPTIONAL
PERSON.
SHE DIDN'T TRY TO BE SEEN ALL
AROUND THE WHITE HOUSE, BUT SHE
KNEW WHENEVER THE PRESIDENT HAD
A TOUGH DECISION, THE PERSON
THAT GOT HIS EAR LAST WAS
BARBARA BUSH AND SHE MADE A BIG,
BIG DIFFERENCE THAT WAY.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO PUT UP ON
THE SCREEN THE STATEMENT WE JUST
RECEIVED FROM THE PRESIDENT 43
GEORGE W. BUSH.
MY DEAR MOTHER HAS PASSED AT AGE
92.
LAURA, BARBARA, JENNA, AND I ARE
SAD, BUT OUR SOULS ARE SETTLED.
BARBARA BUSH WAS A FABULOUS
FIRST LADY AND A WOMAN UNLIKE
ANY OTHER WHO BROUGHT LEVITY,
LOVE, AND LITERACY TO MILLIONS.
I'M LUCKY THAT BARBARA BUSH WAS
MY MOTHER.
WE THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PRAYERS AND GOOD WISHES.
HOW DID BARBARA BUSH MANAGE TO
BE AS FAMOUS AS SHE WAS A
QUESTION MARK SHE WAS PRETTY
FAMOUS FOR HER FIRST LADY, MORE
THAN MOST I THINK, AND YET
PRETTY WIDELY LIKED ON A
BIPARTISAN LEVEL, SHE WAS NEVER
CONTROVERSIAL OR DIVISIVE.
HOW DID SHE DO THAT?
>> SHE TRIED TO MAKE SURE SHE
WASN'T CONTROVERSIAL OR
DIVISIVE.
SHE WAS CLEAR IN HER OPINIONS,
PEOPLE KNEW WHERE SHE STOOD, SHE
DIDN'T STRADDLE ANYTHING IN THE
FACT OF WHAT YOU SAW WAS WHAT
YOU GOT.
IT WAS LIKE THAT FROM DAY ONE
ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE A
QUIET DINNER WITH THE PRESIDENT
AND MRS. BUSH LAST MONTH.
WE WENT DOWN AND DID AN EVENT AT
THE BUSH LIBRARY AND SHE LOOKED
A LITTLE EXTRA FRAIL, BUT IN THE
CONDITION THAT WE NOW KNOW SHE
WAS IN, IT WAS A FUN DINNER.
WE TALKED ABOUT OLD TIMES, WE
REMINISCED, WE LAUGHED A LITTLE
BIT AND WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
SHE NEVER LET HER PERSONAL
SITUATION IMPACT THE QUALITY OF
INTERACTION SHE HAD WITH PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SHE LIVED THROUGH
THE WHOLE SPAN OF MODERN
AMERICAN HISTORY, 92 EUROS.
SHE WAS BORN BEFORE THE
GREAT DEPRESSION IN A WORLD THAT
NO LONGER EXISTS AND THEN SHE
PASSES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
WORLD THAT IS BECOMING A BIG
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
I WONDER HOW SHE RESPONDED TO
THAT.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> SHOULD NOT ONLY LIVED THROUGH
IT, SHE HELPED SHAPE IT.
I THINK SHE WAS VERY AWARE OF
WHAT A CRUCIAL TIME THAT SHE AND
THE PRESIDENT SPENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT WAS A REAL HINGE POINT.
GEORGE H.W. BUSH WAS THE ONE WHO
HAD A VERY DELICATE DIPLOMATIC